[Music]
smoked haddock one of my favorite fish
delicious
highly sustainable packed with protein
lightly smoked there's not a dye smoke
there's a big difference so you haven't
got that bright yellow tinge
so much better
next baby spinach there's a spinach
that's very young full of zinc great
flavor little teaspoon volleyball knob
of butter
that little touch of oil stops the
butter from burning
it looks like a lot of spinach
but it's going to disintegrate almost by
two-thirds
i'm cooking spinach in butter
open up the top of my pepper mill so the
pepper becomes almost like sort of
cracked pepper lots of fine
once your spinach has reduced down by
two-thirds add in your cubes of smoked
haddock
tarragon it's got that nice vinegary
flavor quite tart
pick off the little buds from the stalks
keep hold of these and grateful when
you're making italian vinegar red wine
vinegar tarragon stalks in
chop the tarragon into your creme
fraiche
little season
now
grain mustard goes brilliantly well with
havoc
incredible this mustardy herbie creme
fresh will work equally well partnered
with grilled chicken
the haddock's starting to flake because
it's smoked lightly cured it cooks so
quickly your creme
it's
fraiche
now it's almost like the beginning of
the perfect fish pie but as opposed to
putting pastry on top the eggs are going
to bake on top so you've got this
wonderful egg crust
turn the gas off
now
crack your eggs around the outside
just a little twist of pepper
get the remainder of your cream fresh
and put a little dollop
in between that adds richness to the egg
whites
into the oven at 180
for 10 to 12 minutes
[Music]
whilst the haddock and eggs bake
together i can knock up a simple spring
onion garnish
in professional kitchen chefs refuse to
use the top of the spring onions but i
love that nice dark green flavor it's
less harsh than the white
the smell of baked mustard you can't
beat
[Music]
that
is beautiful
spinach has almost melted in with a hat
up now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
wow
my ultimate hearty breakfast smoked
haddock and spinach baked eggs so packed
with protein and iron you'll be raring
to dive into the day ahead
[Music]
roasted tomato soup
beautiful vine tomatoes the riper the
tomatoes the better the soup
take the core out get your thumb and
place it half a centimetre underneath
the tip of your knife place it in and
then just twist around that's the only
part of the tomato that we're not using
red onion
and garlic
red onion because it's sweeter than a
white onion
slice your onions and your garlic
nice and fine
traditionally be making it in a pot it's
so much better to start it off on top of
the stove the searing the tomatoes and
the garlic when it goes in the oven
you actually roast the tomatoes and they
don't stew there's a big difference in
flavor
be quite generous with the olive oil it
makes the soup nice and glossy shiny
salt pepper and then a little teaspoon
of cayenne just gives it that heat but
it's not as fierce as chilli
take your tomatoes and just slice them
in half
and then
a little touch of sugar that's gonna
help intensify the sweetness
a little sprinkle
of aged bottled vinegar gives that nice
dark rich acidity
to the soup
into the oven 20 25 minutes
180.
to make my soup even more irresistible
i'm going to make a punchy sun-dried
tomato pesto to drizzle over the top
now i'm making this in a pestle and
mortar because you feel
so much more in control
and you're not depending on a blade
that's whizzing around at a thousand
miles an hour
next in a dry pan toast off some pine
nuts
toast them the absolute max and then in
the smell in there is incredible
parmesan
lightly grate that
this is where it starts to become creamy
extra virgin olive oil
doesn't need salt because the parmesan
is going to season it for you
and just take a couple of tablespoons of
the oil the sun-dried tomatoes are in
really helps to make that stunning pesto
i can smell those roasted tomatoes want
them out
wow
next pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes
put your spoon through those tomatoes
they break up instantly bring that up to
the boil let it simmer for three or four
minutes
i want to make it a little bit more
creamy now
cream in
give that a little stir you can keep it
rustic and you get your masher in
and you've got that nice thick
rich
chunky tomato soup
or
get yourself a stick blender
blitzing it like that you delays the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom
that's delicious
to make my lunch extra hearty i'm going
to knock up a deliciously gutsy version
of cheese on toast to go with my tomato
soup
boss rabbit
an absolute classic i'm gonna make a
roux 50 grams of butter three nice
tablespoons of flour and that's all aru
is basically traditionally you would use
flour butter
and milk
but in welsh rabbit the milk is often
cheekily substituted for a stiff slug of
stout
gives it that strong gutsy flavor
i want it nice and thick make sure those
lumps are out
a nice teaspoon of dijon mustard and
then season it
nice and spicy moisture sauce gives it
that delicious intriguing flavor now
that smells amazing
almost brings tears to your eyes
beautiful
now boss rabbit wouldn't be a stunning
welsh rabbit without rich mature cheese
soap and a great
montgomery cheddar
goes well with a beer
and drop that in
really important to put this in while
the roux
is still nice and hot because the cheese
melts
now for the bread
i prefer a good rustic country loaf that
will stand up to my hardcore topping
i want that nice crisp
base to my welsh rabbit so toast it both
sides
[Music]
spread that beautiful cheesy berry spicy
mixture
just great
got a blister
and bubble congratonate
god
a little splash alien perry
and back under the krill for 90 seconds
in one delicious
creamy roasted tomato soup it's coming
back to me all those days i had off
school i used to purposely lie about
feeling ill just to get a bowl of my
mother's tomato soup
how bad was that
but my god it was worth it
oh
now
my welsh rabbit
[Music]
look at those babies that just takes
cheese on toast to another level
wow
roasted creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto served with the
most amazing delicious welsh rabbit
i feel like ringing in sick
[Music]
beef and ale with mustard dumplings
[Music]
and helping in the kitchen is my
youngest tilly
[Music]
tilly
first things first i'd like you to
season the stewing steak
a nice spoon of flour
mix yeah
good girl what's the flower going to do
dad the flower helps to brown the beef
our seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor and thicken the stew
i feel a bit like marshmallows
they do feel a little bit marshmallow
don't they look at the size of the
chunks of the beef
i'm going to cut my carrots literally
similar similar size that's right does
that mean they'll cook equally that's
right now these
are little pearl onions i'm going to put
them in hole as well everything
has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burn garlic before
oh matilda
she promised you weren't gonna mention
that
what is that
time
time and what are they
bay leaves bailey's good girl tablespoon
of oil in
the beef goes in first okay
in
a really nice color it's a beautiful
color
remember the carrots thyme in
good girl
garlic
pearl onions in
good
give that a really good mix up
[Music]
stews are very easy to make providing at
the beginning you give it a little bit
of love
now that's all beautifully browned
that is beer and that's going to deglaze
the pan
adding beer or stout helps to tenderize
the beef and give it a hearty delicious
flavor
and that's the only way i want you to
taste beer
in a stew
yeah
i want to add in a couple of teaspoons
of tomato puree please
in fact three please
because it's so nice there's one final
thing in there cover the student's date
with the bee stock give that a little
mix with daddy please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables in when you
serve it to be oh yes is the garlic
going to be burnt no excuse me
right and we always put the lid with a
little bit just a little bit so it can
breathe that's right and not make the
stew all watery into the oven at 150
please tell us for about two and a half
hours and now
you can focus on your homework
fun
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato classics in one twice baked
bubbling squid jacket potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute in butter and add a dash of
water until tender
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside and cook
through in the middle
slice them in half and scoop out the
soft potato center
then mash with a couple of knobs of
butter mix in the cabbage and season to
taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes or until the tops are nice
and crispy and golden
two delicious hearty potato classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
right homework done yep beef stew is
chewing stewing let's get on with our
delicious hearty pet art i've been
looking forward to this
you and i chef i'm going to prep the
pears so if you peel
i'll top and tail
into quarters pears go soft in the oven
very very quickly so we're going to put
them on a tart you'll need to leave them
whole half or in quarter
what's that in there
ginger that's right a stem ginger so you
need stem ginger and fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup good girl and some
brown sugar to your quartered pears
and then just grab some fresh ginger off
you go so it's a bit of a um different
one to grate this because it doesn't
really come through like the cheese no
i'm gonna make that a little bit zesty
now we've got some lemons some lemon
zest in there
right what we need to do now is give
that
a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff where you make it it's so
easy to do
so give me your finger
that's my center point i want you to get
the pears going around
like that a really nice circle
it's difficult isn't it because the
pears keep on sliding all over the place
yeah so egg wash the outside and i'm
going to show you a little trick
so you lift that up so i see egg wash
acting like a bit of a glue that's right
crimple this with our finger
and the pastry forms this nice little
shelf like a little money bag are you
going to do anything with the spare
pears oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
ginger
let me go around mike with your glue we
might glue just on top
tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar so that
caramelizes it and colors the pears
beautifully it's a bit like snow isn't
it now that glaze is the pastry so the
pastry has this really nice shine on
there as well finally the lemon on top
and then put that there
180 and in she goes
can you smell the beef smells delish
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it look at that i want you to
just i was hoping you'd ask just have a
little taste
[Music]
how's that taste now
i'm not allowed anymore
all right dumpling time flour in please
i'm using self-raising flour for a
fluffy result but if you like your
dumplings hard use plain flour
next the dumpling essential suet
that makes the dumplings nice and moist
thank you
followed by a generous dollop of grain
mustard
two fingers
start rolling the fingers round and i've
got a touch of warm water here
your fingers are now a nice little whisk
my fingers are getting tired right now
put your hand in there now you should
bring
all that dough together
i'll show you the best way to get that
nice and clean sprinkle the flour on
your hands rub them together
all that will come off nice
that's a good way isn't it
now we've got this wonderful dumpling
mixture
how squidgy is that
a little flower on your hands okay
roll these lengthways
and then i want you to
fall in like that in your hand
off we go
smell that mustard in there
huh
oh
come on he'd never trust you with
something like that
yes please
silly
gently let's go in
at 12 o'clock
one o'clock
12 in the center
and put that back into the oven for 20
minutes to cook the dumplings now if you
open the door for daddy i'm going to
take out that
oh
tart
smells so nice doesn't it
our pet art has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby that looks good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please
nice and gently all the way around good
girl
little taps
the others are gonna love this it looks
a bit like a snowy cake doesn't it good
job
now very carefully carry that
to the table
how nice does that look delicious okay
i'll check on the dumplings
now
look
they've sort of doubled in size
whoa definitely
a final sprinkle of chopped parsley and
our stew is ready for the table
i might have to have a quick taste
before we go
just to check i mean we don't have to be
sure we have to be very sure
[Music]
hmm
that is an amazing hearty beef stew with
dumplings right the twice baked loaded
potatoes
and we are ready
this is my ultimate hearty dinner
a comforting rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings and twice baked bubbling
squeak jacket potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied a rich and zingy
pear and ginger galette
you